mother's day is this sunday a lot of
people like to do brunch
with their moms i know i always loved it
i thought it'd be fun to invite a
popular
food blogger on the show for a cooking
segment
so here's the author of the blog beth
bakes
with one of her favorite brunch recipes
welcome beth
hi conan thanks for having me we're
delighted to have you
what are we baking today beth i'm gonna
show you the recipe for my cinnamon
brioche french toast
exactly as written on my blog oh wow
that does look delicious
okay how do we make this you start with
flour
my mother always made sure we had enough
flour to make something special on
mother's day
in ukraine where she grew up everyday
goods like flour
were scarce you see they had to
implement ratcheting measures to offset
the post-war recession
i'm sure they did yeah i bet that's
fascinating but we're just short on time
so
can you just move ahead to the recipe
please of course
i know all about limited time my mother
was talented enough to open her own
bakery but she had to spend
so much time washing my father's
underwear
what are the other ingredients it's a
cinnamon brioche so i'm guessing there's
cinnamon in there right
yes the best cinnamon comes from the
island of ceylon
normally i don't like to ask people
where they're from because what does it
matter
my parents found me on a wood pile but
they loved me just the same
i'm sorry is there like a skip to recipe
button i could kind of push
well the truth is any group of people
can be a family when my
ex-husband took us to live on that
commune we called them the family
because
we all worshiped the same leader he was
a short man and he had a very long beard
oh
he was intoxicating i remember it didn't
matter what your body looked like
no one cared what shape you had
what scars you had no one cared
we loved every inch of one another's
body
and we used to use beats to color our
hair
i still do can you tell so i found a
beat
i took it to the leader's shirt and he
said that's not a beat that's
a turnip so back to the dungeon
i tried to claw the wall and you
couldn't get up there
i didn't have the upper body strength no
one did
but you know i really had a lot of time
to think in those dungeons
i really did oh conan
uh i'm about to share the recipe oh
recipe
yes the recipe i'd love to see the
recipe
oh but real quick let me show you some
photos of adorable children eating my
french toast they're not my
children but they did wander where did
they wander in from
we kind of took over a town it was a
very rural town
and uh so these children i guess they
were on a field trip i don't know there
was a petting zoo nearby
i don't i didn't we're gonna take a
little break uh wonderful show tonight w
kamau bell is here yes maybe he's got a
recipe
oh you know what i love bells my parents
used to ring one before we were allowed
to eat we couldn't eat until they rang
the bell
so it always makes me think of food i'm
kind of like a pavlov's dog that way
ding ding ding ooh i start salivating
yeah okay
well i am salivating for this segment to
end
[Laughter]
okay i'm gonna go we'll take a break
we'll be right back you should see my
back ugh
it is hideous it's awful oh so many
ripples and
and i have a lot of acne on it i mean it
doesn't really bother me
because i can't see it but other people
can i hear a lot about it from all of my
husbands